[Music]
welcome to day three of Google next
thank you for attending the session
about modernizing and migrating to cloud
my name is Asha tirstrup party and I am
the cloud customer engineer with Google
cloud who is speaking with me today is
John Shearwood and Jonathan Lee from CBS
Interactive I would let them introduce
as they come on the stage I will quickly
touch upon why part of the cloud white
enterprises are migrating to the cloud
can I get a quick show of hands how many
of you own your own power grid to supply
electricity to your houses
as expected I got only one hand but as
we know owning our own infrastructure is
not really a cost efficient way to
supply electricity to our houses
similarly enterprises are realizing that
owning and operating an own datacenter
is not really a cost efficient real
differentiator comes what kind of
products and services we deliver to our
end customers that being said there are
top for migration drivers for the
enterprises of any size to migrate to
the cloud the top one being the growth
lot of organizations are looking to
release new products and services to
serve their end customers they want to
tools and capabilities to react to the
changing market conditions and with the
technology you can serve your customer
across the globe whether they are
sitting in Africa Asia or right here in
North America and the risk mitigation
risk is not only about how do we prevent
attacks to our system but also meeting
the compliance regulatory compliance
whether it's around data residency or
having a secured platform to serve our
customers and build a reliable
infrastructure to serve our applications
to end customers in case of any natural
disease
Calamity and as you heard that Google
Cloud has regions across the globe that
way you can bring your applications and
services closer to your end customers
and have a reliable and fault-tolerant
architecture for your applications
innovation is one of the key drivers
customers are looking to move to the
cloud the way the all these technologies
whether it's around artificial
intelligence machine learning Big Data
the cloud provides it is not only
helping enterprises to explore new
frontier to serve their customers but
also differentiate from their
competition and build a reputation as a
forward-looking organizations while
doing all this cost is also one of the
most important factor cloud provides
various productivity tools the
automations capabilities and also let
you have the infrastructure based on
your varying demands whether it's a peak
or off-peak you can set accordingly and
choose the financial model that works
best for the organizations now cloud is
not only about innovation and
disruptions it's also about how
organizations are transforming they are
evolving to have a applications or the
environment which can serve the whole
ecosystem their customers their
employees their partners and there are
typically four stages first is the
divest as I mentioned the owning and
operating in your infrastructure is not
the key differentiator for most of the
organization make it someone sells
problem make it Google's problem to run
your infrastructure efficiently securely
and reliably all that at a lower cost
invest in the areas which help you
differentiate whether it is around
artificial intelligence or machine
learning and Google has been doing it
for many many years let us help you make
you successful empower your developers
with the tools and the capabilities and
the platform so they can build the
exciting applications to drive the
customer engagement help your
employees be more invested with the
business and grow your partners and
overall all these transformation comes
around three things the right culture
the right technology and right processes
even the large organizations are
realizing that size is advantage to them
and they are looking to transform how
they do business and how they serve
their customers at a very high level
than flustered infrastructure
modernization can be said how do we have
a secured performant and reliable
architecture and the platform at a lower
cost it could all start with the compute
which is the first journey to many of
the organizations whether you are
looking to build new applications using
serverless technologies or you are
looking to migrate your applications to
the cloud whether it is a disaster
recovery or hosting any of your custom
applications such as ICP and others the
storage many of the organization's
whether they are in the media and
entertainment space or in healthcare
financial services and many other they
have lot of data sitting on the tape
at Google we provide the different type
of storage which works best based on the
type of media you are looking to move or
content you are looking to move to the
cloud network as you heard sundar saying
that we have laid out the fabric under
Pacific and looking to do under the
Atlantic as well network is the key no
matter what we do whether we are
connecting to on Prem to cloud or having
hybrid architecture or also providing
services to our customer or we are doing
some specialized tools around a IML and
everything so it's all about highly
scalable highly reliable data center or
the capabilities in the cloud what
Google cloud provides actually so just
quickly the quick question comes to
everybody is mind hey how do we start so
it starts with how do you assess your
applications what type of applications
you have in the portfolio and what they
are doing and other thing comes about
planning your application planning your
move the dependency there are some
applique
which maybe cloud-ready but there are
some which may not be even ready for the
cloud so plan your order and pick a path
whether it is migrating or lifting and
shifting or reor collecting your
applications and while doing this how do
you optimize your applications and
operations and have a constant feedback
loop to get started and optimize your
journey we have large number of
customers who are modernizing and magnet
into GCP and it's my privilege to invite
John Shearwood VP of engineering from
CBS Interactive to share his journey
John thank you hi everyone
Oh clicker when we started scene at in
1995 it was all about helping thousands
of people get the most from their
computer here at C net we've been
testing Windows 95 for some time it's
new it's different then came the
internet you've got mail HDTV and the
smart phone today Apple is going to
reinvent the phone the world had
officially gone digital since then
CNET has helped hundreds of millions of
people master a connected life
do-it-yourself tech hey Siri close the
shades
okay let's actually start with what we
do know let's check out what it can do
how to kid-proof your streaming services
when there's massive change market
confusion and untapped opportunities
you'll find CNET making tech make sense
all right hi everyone I'm John Sherwood
vice president of engineering and
technology for the CNET Media Group part
of CBS Interactive we're going to talk
today about our journey to GCP which we
completed last year I'm going to talk
briefly about our migration at a high
level and then jonathan lee director of
devops it's going to come up he's going
to go into some details and then take
you through a demo of a system that the
team built to replay our traffic before
we actually sent production traffic into
GCP first off a little bit of history
about Siena we were actually founded in
1994 as a television come we were
producing television shows about
technology quickly pivoted to the web in
95 in 19 I'm sorry in 2000 CNET acquired
ZDNet to form C net networks I am proud
to say that I actually wrote the code
for that page there on the right
I know what you're thinking yes Ziff
Davis did hire children to write code
back then so CBS Interactive was CBS
bought see net networks in 2008 to form
CBS Interactive CBS Interactive is a
collection of all the brands you see
there and there's actually a lot more
that I couldn't fit on the slide with
more than 350 million visitors each
month to our properties we are the 14th
largest property in the world and we're
the seventh largest in the US just to
give you some perspective the top five
include the likes of Microsoft Amazon
Google I should have said Google first
Facebook so we're in a good company
they're seeing a media group that my
team is responsible for is the majority
of the non CBS brands and we decided to
start our journey with CNET which is
actually the largest brand of that
portfolio mainly because it had a
relatively modern stack that we were
working with we had gone through a
modernization a few years before
this is what I put this up here it's
kind of an eye chart I just want to kind
of show you when we said we were gonna
move CNET into GCP this is what we were
dealing with in the beginning but you
know basically it's a PHP web app
fronted by a CDN proxy behind that it's
varnish and then we have AP eyes behind
that it's [ __ ] solar my sequel and then
we have Java applications that are doing
the processing for a big data bringing
in our product catalog and pricing
information so while our journey
actually started a little less than two
years ago CBS Interactive has actually
been in the cloud for probably more than
a decade but some of its properties so
there has been some experience there and
not all of its been good a few brands
went in several years ago only to be
pulled out pretty quickly once we got
the sticker shock of how expensive it
was to run but that tipping point passed
a few years ago and now it's much more
cost-effective and efficient for us to
run in the cloud we so just quickly
getting in here of course there's the
operational efficiencies we can spin up
servers and hardware within a matter of
minutes we don't have to go through long
procurement processes that we used to
have to go through of course you know we
would always over provision so we could
handle our peak load but then we'd have
a bunch of hardware sitting around that
we weren't using and we had to do a
whole lot of guessing upfront you know
what we were going to need so now we can
quickly spin up what we need at the time
that we need it we can get prototypes
going really quickly and then of course
there's the cost efficiencies and
transparency so we can actually see and
pay for what we're using before we used
to have this model where we would pay
for the costs of the data center and the
teams that managed that by the number of
servers we had running in the data
center so what happened was at the end
of every year when they did that
allocation they were
a mad scramble for everyone to shut down
as many servers as we could so we
wouldn't be left holding the bag as soon
as that process was done everyone would
start up servers again and it'd be the
Wild West of course we want to be able
to leverage managed services we don't
want to be as a she Tosh said we don't
want to be doing all of the the core
infrastructure we want to be solving
business problems core to our business
even though we're very we've been around
for a while and so we have a history of
having to build things ourselves like
see ICD and search we actually developed
solar and release that but now we don't
have to do that and we don't really want
to be doing that security of course for
a long time there was this mantra of oh
the cloud is not secure that's not
actually the case
it's just you have to think about it in
a different way you can't just draw a
nice ring around your data center you
actually have to think about the
components and how you're going to
secure them we could leverage Google's
network their global network can get
really close and to our customers much
faster and we also leveraged Direct
Connect from our data center into GCP
and that was really important for us as
we did our migration and then of course
high availability disaster recovery we
were running in a single data center in
Phoenix so of course there's problems
with that something happened core
networking router or you know something
like that it could take down everything
and take us a while to recover from that
Google we can spin things up in multiple
zones and regions
I will admit when we first launched we
actually went out in one region one zone
we did like four like and that was
really just to kind of keep the scope of
what we were trying to do as small as
possible but soon after we launched we
went multi zone and that was relatively
quick and painless for the people who
actually did the work okay so how do we
do it
I'll bring Ashutosh is slide back up
here and we basically went through this
process we assessed what
our applications we're doing what our
systems and infrastructure were we
planned what we could do what we could
move and when we could move it and
looked at all the dependencies and
complexity but we didn't want to wait
too long we wanted to get migrating
because GCP was new to us and we knew
that it was a lot that we probably
wouldn't know and we were gonna have to
learn along the way and then of course
we optimized like I said we went
multi-zone afterwards so we went to set
off to figure out what we were gonna do
how we want to do it for each system we
came up with a design plan for each one
could we lab leverage managed services
if not did we have the expertise
in-house to set up those systems and
maintain them for example we didn't
really want to set up and maintain our
own Hadoop cluster so we decided to
leverage data proc as a managed service
but some of those decisions required
then some refactoring and had impact we
knew we can containerize running VMs so
some of the things we wanted to do was
you know pretty straightforward and then
once we had a rough idea of the design
we would compare that with a straight
lift and shift to see if you know just
doing a straight lifting shift was
actually more cost-effective but I will
say we were kind of morally opposed to
doing just straight lifting shifts we
wanted to gain some wins out of moving
into the cloud and not you know end up
with the same thing
just in a different location while we
were doing that a broader steering group
was solving these problems across CBS
Interactive and these were things that I
didn't want my team to have to be
responsible for and quite frankly they
needed to be solved across the entire
company how are we going to manage users
and their access what was a networking
going to look like how we're going to
connect to the data center how was the
network going to be managed security
what were the policies what were those
going to be and how are they going to be
enforced and then of course billing how
are we going to divide up the costs and
make sure that we did get the
transparency that we really wanted at a
high love
this is what our project look like so as
I said we started with a design and
architecture and did that for a couple
of months and then we decided as I said
some of our back-end systems were much
more complex and we're going to require
more thought and refactoring so they
were going to take a little bit longer
we knew our front-end stack was a little
bit simpler
and we could get that out more quickly
so we decided to break the project up
into two phases and also I'm kind of
impatient and I didn't want us to have
to wait until everything was done before
we started learning so that's why we
went with two phases the first phase was
really all our front end reads and that
allowed traffic to come in to those
systems the rights stayed in our legacy
infrastructure this also gave us the
ability to slowly ramp up traffic into
the cloud so we didn't have to flip a
switch which was very important to us so
this is what the phase 1 architecture
looked like you can see there on the
right our rights were going into our
legacy data center and then our legacy
of web apps we're still serving traffic
there from those data sources we were
replicating those data sources over into
GCP through that direct connect and then
we had our containerized applications
sitting in GCP and then we used our CDN
as a proxy to slowly ramp traffic up
over to GCP over the course of a few
weeks we did that and then we had a
hundred percent of our traffic running
in GCP I
I'll put an asterisk there was almost
all of our traffic all the reads so then
we were able to when all of our back-end
systems were ready to go
then we already had most of the traffic
over there so actually the the launch
went really smoothly we were able to
break replication turn on those new
write services to point at those
replicas that we're now the masters and
this is what we ended up with and
doesn't this look way
better than that first graphic I showed
you guys then coming back to this this
is actually phase point five so this is
our infrastructure setup before we
started proxying traffic over we wanted
a way to load tests and do functional
testing of that system so the team
developed a replay system that could
take our traffic using stackdriver
cloud pub/sub and cloud functions replay
our traffic in real time allowed us to
dial that up and down and we were able
to actually I think run like 300 percent
of our traffic over into the new system
so it really gave us a way to fine-tune
and configure our new system before any
real users actually had to experience it
and Jonathan Lee he's going to come up
and give you a demo of that so of course
this was a huge effort and most
importantly a huge team effort
and a ton of details that I haven't even
gotten into and Jonathan will start to
get into some of those it required a ton
of focus collaboration across my team
across CBS interactive with Google we
also had some partners that we worked
with Deloitte provided some contractors
for us and I'd like to say thank you to
them many of them are in the room today
so thank you one of which who is the
star student sitting in the front here
is Jonathan Lee he's director of DevOps
for the CNET Media Group I'd like to
bring him up and take you through some
of the details this is one of the
critical systems that makes the net CNET
this is our catalog back-end system so
just wanted to call it out along with
pricing which is a similar system but
both systems take advantage of a lot of
managed services so they're taking
advantage of bigquery data proc App
Engine for cron preemptable VMs pub/sub
and then cloud storage so and then
building on top of that for our testing
strategy this is a front-end proxy so
this is where all the user traffic came
in from our users it came in through
Akamai where we did that traffic
splitting that John covered it hits
the Google load balancers that then
proxied over to varnish instances the
varnish instances did not support HP s
so we had to use a leverage another
open-source product called hitch and
what hitch does is it just terminates
the HTS and talks to varnish over the
box and then from there we can talk to
the internal swarm load balancers and
then off to container land for our
front-end so one of the things we want
to do during our migration to the cloud
is to adopt infrastructure as a code
that allowed us to do more automation so
we leveraged Jenkins and patchy court
products so Jenkins Jenkins we talked to
packer and terraform and provision our
compute instances and then terraform
would actually provision out those
packer images to our infrastructure so
we managed to standardize on Ubuntu as
our base image we had three flavors 1404
for our legacy applications 1604 was
what we tried to adopt for most of our
newer applications and all of our dr.
swarm stuff and then we started
leveraging 18:04 as they got released so
jumping back to the security that john
mentioned earlier we leveraged a lot of
security in our infrastructure we had
tenable which basically just told us
when we need to detach the OS so we had
signal science that's basically said in
our engine X and was the laughs for our
applications we had a classic that did
the container image scanning vault which
kept all of our secrets and then we also
which is not on here digital and check
marks which also did static analysis of
the code so what did the security
integration look like so tying in all
those security tools we had tenable that
would actually be baked into the Packer
without registering any of the images
that got pushed up the Cloud Storage
terraform would actually push out those
Packer images
then registering those those VMs as they
were spun up with tenable then we had
signal science running on the compute
incent engines inside the engine tax and
then obviously vault could be used for
shipping any sort of secrets over to the
VMS for containers building on top of
the last slide we also leveraged Jenkins
to push to our own private docker
registry which we just ran the open
source docker registry we're in the
process of moving over to GTR so that's
a another managed service we're going to
take advantage of we use Nexus to manage
any sort of artifacts and then as
Jenkins was pushing out those containers
to swarm during that build process we
would leverage aqua sec to do the image
scanning to make sure they were in
clients and then we also ran aqua second
for Sur inside of the swarm clusters
which could tell us if any of the
containers were out of policy so as for
doctors doctor services most of our
state lists applications we're doctor
eyes and we had a pretty standard set up
where we tried to follow best practices
which is one process per container so we
had containers that ran the nginx and
then those actually talked internally in
the swarm cluster over to PHP Python
whatever other application languages we
were running so now I want to get into
three of the things that are most
critical for any cloud migration and
this should be useful for just about
everyone so the first one is logging you
have to have logging to be able to
migrate to the cloud successfully so
before we started our GC key migration
we decided to integrate a lot of our
tooling into GCP before actually moved
any applications over so we needed to
get those logs from the on-prem data
data center into GCP so we tried to
leverage all of the tooling that was on
the machines without actually editing
any of them or adding any new software
or anything like that so for solar for
instance we had our syslog running on
the VMS inside of our data center we
just had those remote
ship those logs over to fluent D boxes
that were running in GCP those fluent D
boxes basically just proxy those over
and authorized them with the GCP
platform and then ship those over to
stackdriver logging so and then for
container container eyes workload we
leveraged another open source logging
driver called logs about and that
effectively did the same thing that our
sis logs did which just shipped the logs
over to GCP so once they got into GCP
got into stack driver logging we now had
visibility across our on-prem data
center using GCPs stackdriver logging so
from there we decided that well we need
to get people on board with TCP a lot of
people haven't been trained on that so
we decided to leverage on another
architecture how many people know about
the ELQ stack okay so for the people
that don't know what that is that's a
last search log stash and Cabana log
stash actually parses the logs ships
them to elasticsearch which stores them
and then Cabana is like a pretty GUI
that sits on the front of it so we we
ship the stack driver logs over to pub
sub from there that got that got pulled
from log stash and then got adjusted
into that Alec stack once we migrated
over to GCP fast forward a few months we
were able to remove that fluent D dummy
boxes and just ship straight into stack
driver logging so not much change there
so here we kind of have just the two
logging systems we have the stack driver
logging that people were getting ramped
up on on how to use and leverage and
then over on the right we had Cabana
which is a bit more friendly to new
people coming into logging so we'll go
over that a little bit in the demo so
after you have logging in place the next
most critical thing is is monitoring
obviously so you need to know what your
systems are doing where there's are
coming in when you need to look at the
logs and and dig in so we leveraged
quite a few open source
Prometheus being the big one so and then
Griffin ax for displaying those
Prometheus metrics and then also with
alerting you need you know in the
monitoring you need alerting so we had a
note advisor for the system level
metrics that got shipped into Prometheus
see advisor for container level metrics
and then we had a black box exporter
that can actually kind of work similar
to Pingdom where it can just do a health
check to the application to make sure
that they're still up on the front end
side we didn't we didn't really have to
worry too much about front-end
performance but we did still test it
just to make sure that we weren't going
to impact in users but we leveraged a
couple other open-source tools one being
site speed io and and then that
integrated with webpagetest so we ran
those side-by-side comparing the
front-end performance of our legacy
application and our DCP application and
then last but not least for the
front-end we also integrated with Akamai
impulse which allowed us to get real
user monitoring from the end-users
browsers
while we were doing that migration so we
could actually lay them side by side and
we could see if there was any
performance problem with problems to our
end-users so with all that in place we
decided that we needed to get more
experience in GCP so we decided to do
tabletop exercises and within those
tabletop exercises we could do anything
from just stopping servers to get people
that operational experience of debugging
and figuring out what's going on bad
code deployments thundering herd problem
how many people have heard of that any
one dude okay so thundering herd problem
is basically just you you stop all the
traffic and then all of a sudden you
just send a bunch of traffic like
exponential amount of traffic so we tend
to have live events things like CES and
Black Friday and things like that so
we'll get a surge of traffic if you know
iPhone gets released or something like
that so we wanted to test that scenario
let's get into the one of the testing
strategies that we came up internally
which was the live replay of production
traffic so we brainstormed this in-house
after evaluating with several external
third parties and open source products
they didn't quite fit our needs
internally we wanted to replicate live
traffic not just simply replay a
percentage of a specific page or types
of page or anything that's static like
that so a lot of the open source tools
allow you to replay things like an
article page at 10 percent reviews pages
at 70 percent so it was very static and
you had to pass it a static list of URLs
so going back to that front-end diagram
we leveraged that front end entry point
for our replay test and we and we
realized that all we had to do to test
the entire system in the end is really
just send user traffic like real users
were coming in so let's walk through the
system that we built internally so
obviously you have the end users there
on the right talking to our legacy
Phoenix data center servers from there
we're shipping those logs using our
syslog or logs about over to fluent deep
boxes in GCP from there they get
congested in stackdriver logging from
their pub/sub pub/sub can actually kick
off cloud functions and then within the
cloud functions we actually had the
ability to do any sort of programming or
manipulation of those logs as they came
in so we could introduce errors we could
just dynamically just replay live
traffic we could even time box and
replay certain logs if we wanted to so
and then from there the the cloud
function will actually issue those HTTP
calls over to the GCP boxes so this
entire system allowed us to dynamically
replay any sort of traffic coming into
stackdriver logging and replay it to a
secondary system
this is our just normal cnet.com I
pushed it up to seen it next so what we
want to do is we want to leverage that
sweet retro Cena John mentioned earlier
so what I did is I pulled a retro Cena
next comm and what we're gonna do is
we're gonna send traffic to this one
using those cloud functions we're gonna
replay that traffic over to the retro
system so jump it over to the cloud
console you can see have already
pre-baked all the VMS we have the legacy
swarm cluster that's running that scene
at next comm then we also have a gke
cluster that's running the retro CNET
next comm and then also I have a
separate cluster just that's running
tools so graph on ax they help stack
things like that so reconnect to that so
here we got the kubernetes cluster it's
got four nodes in it pretty standard
stuff jumping into one of the the
workers we can actually look at the logs
so I'm gonna hit play on that so you can
see I'm actually leveraging another tool
it's similar to siege or Vegeta if
anybody's familiar those what you can do
with those is you can just send traffic
directly to a system and you can set a
rate on that and so we're sending over
traffic just in case we don't get enough
hits so from there we can see those
those logs are coming in to that legacy
system I'm actually convinced we can
actually see a few people actually
coming in but you can see that it's the
actual Vegeta system because it has the
the go-go HTTP client and then from
there we can export out to pub/sub so we
have a traffic replay export that's
shipping over to the pub subtopics just
a note if you do have exports out and
you want to save a little bit of money
and actually put in exclusions on your
your logs so that they don't actually
get stored into stackdriver logging but
they will still get shipped over to
pub/sub so we do that to save a little
bit of money it's disabled right now so
on the topic we have the topic from the
export from law stackdriver logging it
has two subscriptions in it right now we
jump over to that one is actually
shipping over to that cloud function and
the other one is actually getting pulled
from a nailed stack that I'm actually
running in that tools swarm cluster so
if we take a look over at those those
tools workers we actually have an elk
stack running in there pulling those
logs in real time there refresh on here
so you can see so we can see those logs
are coming in in real time and what that
allows us to do for the developers this
gives them an easy user interface for
them to get up and running with
filtering logs so they get these nice
little buttons where they can include
and exclude different filters and and
track down any sort of issues so jumping
over to the replay system so now we have
a cloud function that's actually getting
messages from the logs so you can see
here we have that cloud function
actually running right now it's it's
issuing about a 50 requests a second
over to the new system if we jump into
the source code I'm gonna dive a little
bit into the source code the source code
is pretty straightforward
we're using node 8 and using request
promise so with those request promises
we're setting up the domain setting up
the user agent we can actually set a
percentage inside the node code and
replay a certain percentage of that
traffic that's coming into that legacy
system so here we have it set to 10% and
we're only replaying 10% of the 100%
traffic that's coming into the legacy
system so down here we set up the the
request we can put some headers on there
we actually change the user agent so we
know it's coming from the traffic replay
system
and then we can use the promises and
catch those promises whether it's
successful or if it fails so jumping
over to the logs we can actually watch
the logs from the cloud functions in
real time and we can see when the the
functions are executing and when they're
how long they're taking and that sort of
thing jumping back to the kubernetes
cluster we can actually look at the
services we can see that CNN service
that's running the retro site and we can
look at those stackdriver logs from the
new system and we can see that cloud
function is actually coming in in real
time so but I jump over here and I'm
gonna change this real quick from 10 so
I'm gonna edit the cloud function just
so that we can see this here in a second
I'm gonna change it to 100% I'm gonna
play that so while that's going it's
going to change the replay traffic over
from and to 100%
so we have our Prometheus instances
running that's capturing all of our
metrics we have alert manager that we
can actually fire off alerts out to
slack or anything like that I'm
leveraging uncy which is basically a
wrapper for alert manager that gives you
a nice big GUI so it actually had the
cluster big thing here we can actually
look at any of the metrics across any of
the legacy
so here we're looking at the Prometheus
apps of the tools this warm cluster and
we can make sure that we can look at the
individual nose so okay so we can we can
look at the swarm node the nodes
themselves and we can actually see the
uptime of how long those hosts are
running and any sort of system load or
performance that was running on those
same thing for the swarm services we can
see how many replicas are running inside
of that swarm cluster and then also over
on the kubernetes side we can look at
graph on a dashboards for the CNET site
for that retro site and see how many
containers are running inside of
kubernetes same thing with kubernetes or
swarm you can actually start pulling in
metrics and start calculating costs and
build dashboards around that which is
pretty neat and then finally we can mash
all that up together and we can create a
replay dashboard that actually shows our
swarm cluster on the left and our
kubernetes cluster on the right and we
can actually watch it in real time as
traffic's coming in so as we scroll in
down here we can see on the swarm we
have the containers running we can look
at the container CPU the individual
containers in swarm versus the
individual containers in kubernetes
below that we can look at the actual
host VM and look at the CPU usage across
the host
vm's and then also the nodes inside of
kubernetes in the middle we can see how
many requests are coming in per minute
from the legacy system to the new system
and then as we change that cloud
function we can see it react in real
time
with those changes and then below that
we can see requests per minute per host
so we're actually connecting here over
to the ELQ stack that I'm running and
we're actually pulling the logs
individually from the ELQ stack and then
displaying those on this dashboard and
then below that finally we can actually
connect to stack driver monitoring and
we can actually pull metrics from those
manage services as well so here we're
actually looking at the pub sub queue of
unacknowledged messages and we can see
if we're overloading the system with too
many messages and obviously in this demo
I am since I only have one VM running so
cool so that's basically it I'm can we
jump back over to the slides I guess
okay
so what's next I just wanted to call out
some of the tech that we actually used
on CNET the ones bolded here are all the
tech we were able to use for the CNET
migration
obviously there's a lot more that we can
leverage with the managed services as we
move off running our own move structure
and move over to kubernetes and things
like that so and then here's a few of
the upcoming project that we're gonna be
working on in 2019 slash 2020
hopefully leveraging gke memory store
things like that so that we don't have
to run our own VMs so and obviously
leveraging that traffic replay system
that we just went through
[Music]